معك هشام كيف يبدو الوضع حاليا
[موسيقى]
سفيان الوضع يعني الان يشتد نوعا ما هناك
غارات اسرائيليه وهناك رشقات صاروخيه من
فصائل الفلسطينيه المقاومه الفلسطينيه قبل
قليل وقبل اعد قبل دقيقه من الان اطلقت
رشقه صاروخيه باتجاه البلدات والمدن
الاسرائيليه هذه الرشقه لم نرصد مثلها من
قبل منذ اكثر من خمس ساعات الرشقه الاخيره
كانت عند تقريبا التاسعه من مساء امس
والان هي
تتجدد هذه الرشقات الصاروخيه باتجاه
البلدات والمدن الاسرائيليه اذا هذه
الوتيره التي تعمل بها فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وتطلق بها هذه الرشقات باتجاه
البلدات والمدن الاسرائيليه ردا على
استمرار ومواصله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
العدوان على القطاع تاخذ وتيره احيانا
منخفضه واحيانا متسارعه والان تتجدد هذه
الرشقات بعد غارات اسرائيليه عنيفه على
منازل المواطنين وايضا على اراض خاليه في
مدينه غزه وتركزت هذه الغارات هذه الليله
على مدينه غزه
قصفت الطائرات الحربيه والاستطلاعيه منزلا
في منطقه اليرموك وسط مدينه غزه وايضا
منزلا في شرق حي في حي الشجاعيه شرق مدينه
غزه وارضا خاليه ايضا في وسط مدينه غزه
وبالتالي الغارات الاسرائيليه هذه الليله
تاخذ منحنى
تاخذ منحنى متصاعد نوعا ما وتتركز في
مدينه غزه وشرقها بدات بحي الشجاعيه عندما
قصفت منزلا لعائله بهاء ابو العطا وهو
القائد البارز في سرايا القدس والذي
اغتالته اسرائيل في العام 2019
ودمرت جزءا كبيرا من هذا المنزل ومنازل
المواطنين في تلك المنطقه
وكذلك قصفت منزلا في منطقه اليرموك في وسط
مدينه غزه غير بعيد عن هنا وايضا نقل من
هناك
اكثر او نحو ثلاثه اصابات وصفت جراح بعضهم
بالمتوسطه
وبالتالي اسرائيل تكثف الان او تتصاعد هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه وبعد ذلك ترد
المقاومه الفلسطينيه باطلاق رشقات صاروخيه
باتجاه البلدات والمدن الاسرائيليه لكن من
اللافت ان اسرائيل باتت تستخدم وفيه خاصه
في هذه الليله
صواريخ لا تحدث اصوات اي انفجارات الان
رشقه جديده رشقه جديده باتجاه البلدات
والمدن الاسرائيليه سفيان تتصاعد هذه
الرشقات خلال هذه الدقائق القليله الان
رشقه جديده ايضا باتجاه البلدات والمدن
الاسرائيليه اذا المقاومه تكثف من اطلاق
هذه الصواريخ باتجاه البلدات والمدن
الاسرائيليه ونستطيع ان نرى عده نشاطات من
مناطق مختلفه من قطاع غزه تطلقها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه باتجاه البلدات والمدن
الاسرائيليه
وتحدث اصوات انفجارات قويه
هذه
الرشقات تتجه باتجاه مستوطنات غلاف غزه
وايضا مدن اسرائيليه لا نعرف بالتاكيد
ستعلن الفصائل الفلسطينيه هذه الاصوات
المرتفعه للانفجارات هي ناجمه عن القبه
الحديديه التي تطلق هذه الصواريخ باتجاه
في محاوله الاعتراض هذه الصواريخ التي
تطلق من قطاع غزه لكن في كثير من الاحيان
لم نعهد مثلها من قبل ان
تتوقف القبه الصاروخيه تنطلق الصواريخ من
غزه ولا تستطيع القبه الصاروخيه ولا حتى
تنطلق منها صواريخ باتجاه هذه الصواريخ
التي تنطلق من قطاع غزه اذا رشقات صاروخيه
تتجدد من قطاع غزه باتجاه البلدات والمدن
الاسرائيليه